she's a comedian and actress a co-host
on our CBS sister show the talk please
welcome the lovely Cheryl Underwood
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
Cheryl you look so thank you fine thank
you I'm working on you know I have award
is best in about 20 years
20 years
women that saved
tables have gold or clothes yes that you
once you can get in it get in it they
don't call it skinny jeans for nothing
that's right but now of course I've
opted for like a faux sweatpant jeans so
that's uh I don't know what that
territory means what they say jeggings
are out but jeggings are always in for
me me too I'm like I don't care if you
think I've given up on life after two
kids I needed something softer that's
right that's right
um but uh but I do try and I do make an
effort and you know I've been single for
a long time me too and we talk about
this Cheryl like I think it's
interesting I I used to think a lot
about what I wanted I didn't focus on
what I've
come to learn I don't want because I
didn't know there wasn't the Learned
wasn't there yet what is it that you do
want first I want to start at friendship
uh-huh even though I believe in love at
first sight and I even believe in
certain activities could happen if
there's chemistry see I said that see I
say you're going with it right but
picking up what you're putting down
right but but I want I want to be this
person's friend because I'm in another
chapter of my life in another journey of
my life so I want to do it with a friend
what is it that you don't want I I don't
want a man who's mean or rude especially
to other people yes you know
um to me if you're going to be mean and
rude to other people what day is that
going to come back toward me and I don't
want that and and while I want a man
who's attractive you know I want him to
know that it's it's physical attraction
and mental and spiritual attraction
because that physical attraction could
fade but that love always stays the same
yeah so if he's a good person and can be
a good friend and we like to do fun
things together I like sports I like
politics but I like my alone time and I
don't want a man to feel like you always
have to be with me or under me I want
him to let me be with my girlfriends and
know that nothing's happening nothing's
going on I'm just hanging out with my
friends and some of my friends are guys
and platonic guys absolutely like can
women and men be friends most of my male
friends are you know Comics or or people
I do you know charitable work with so we
don't really have that thing going but I
have had crushes on people that I would
like it to go further and then I can
tell when I'm not her when I'm not the
girl for this guy do you tell them that
you have a crush or do you wait till you
see instinctually
that this is going to stay on the
friendship level well there's there
there is a man that I've had a crush on
for decades and wait a minute though
but I've had a crush on him for decades
and he is a performer and I used to sit
in the back of clubs and watch this
person but I would never say anything
because sometimes when you have a crush
on somebody they may be in a
relationship with someone else so I'm
willing to be on the peripheral or be a
good friend to this person would you
ever if you knew this person was single
would you ever tell them is the
Friendship worth risking or not I might
because I'm you know I'm in at an age
where I'm a lot more sure of myself and
I don't really care about being rejected
anymore you know I used to care about
being rejected now I don't care let Tom
Cruise walk through here
well yeah right he's not the only Top
Gun in the room now come on we Top Guns
come on let me fly your plane Tom Cruise
you know because I'm at a different
stage in my life but you know I I would
like to have a companion in my life you
know and do you care about my motto if
you don't work we don't work oh
absolutely and you got to work because
everybody get up in the morning and work
get up if I'm up you up yeah you can't
stay here and play Playstation or eat
cereal while I'm out working I don't
look at the young man going what I can't
say I said no I want a man I feel like
if a guy works at the gas station
I'm with it I know I get free honey buns
and Cheetos at the ethic and gas for
free at the gas station that's right
whatever you're going to be be your own
man yeah and be there and have something
that gets you up every day I couldn't
agree more have you ever tried
to date someone who didn't work and you
went against your own rules and then
realized I I can't or yes yeah and and I
would say you know like I have this song
I play uh the two songs uh Isley
Brothers Let Me Down Easy but it's not
me being let down it's me getting ready
to tell him this is not working
and and
um George Duke I guess you're not the
one for me and I play it for him yeah to
let him know as I walk him out the hotel
I go this is not working I love first of
all I love that it's at a hotel yes um a
interesting setting I get that because I
don't want people because you don't go
too fast with somebody knowing where you
live because then they it's not over for
them and then they show up no that's not
happening so you never know my domicile
until you can I love do not know my
domicile new hashtag not allowed in my
dumbass you better know it you better
know it it's like Elaine are you sponge
worthy that's right domicile don't miss
out
meet the kids too early either I don't
have children but I don't want to meet a
man's children too early if he has
children because you know I Fall In Love
on the first date so you got kids I'm
bringing a pony and a puppy and skis and
all kind of PlayStation and phones and
everything now the kids is like why you
can't be our new Mama because I'd have
brought him everything and but that
sometimes that's not always the best
thing
okay well when we come back we're going
to make a list and check it twice to
find a great guy potentially for Cheryl
who's not rooting for this I am don't go
away
[Music]